happy 4th of July
mmm whoa whoa careful yes are you ready
bitch to do this contest cuz it is every
year and it's like the only reason why I
feel I still am an American despite the
current administration are you ready
yeah I was just gonna say where you got
in your whole thing like I don't know if
I can do it does something happen are
you I didn't boil in the dogs and I was
smelling out that hot water
don't tell me boiling the dogs didn't
make you want the dogs more it didn't I
don't want a dog okay been doing this
for a couple years you do this isn't fun
for me you know I'm not gonna let it get
me down I guess I'll just compete
against myself yeah dude this is your
thing you are gonna kill it I have seven
here today that's all I need to beat my
own record I'm gonna be your old man
rocky old man you got this dude I'm
gonna watch you as much as I can you are
skilled it's you're amazing you are my
best friend for a reason and it's right
now you are the representative of our
country u.s. that your Liberty no
gagging don't get that I'll make it go
you having fun
go drink the dog water don't drink the
salt water
[Music]
you good beat my record what do you
think the stripes are in the American
flag their hot dogs they're boiled and
unboiled hot dogs white and red and
white and red